[Music]
I'm really happy to have great penance a
day the chairman of Walmart and
conversation with Professor Holly
professor Lee is an expert in global
chains supply chains he teaches a global
supply chain class I'm gonna think it's
a great combination for a conversation
with the chairman of Walmart so this is
our second kind of big retail after
hearing about Whole Foods and I hope you
all enjoy the session how thank you
Thank You Bryan and good day everyone
it really is our pleasure to be able to
have a conversation with red pennants
red is a very successful venture
capitalist also chairman of Walmart but
he's also on the board of many many
multinational companies like today we
want to talk about situation perspective
one thing I should also mention that
very proud so good it's great to be here
thank you both to Brian and now for the
opportunity during interesting times
thanks I think both of us are very
dependent on our daily life the state
shelter page I'm very curious and some
students have sent me the questions
ahead that could all mark 16 itself
during this very difficult time in
covered 19
like maintaining health workers as well
as supplies keep coming we heard about
this toilet paper shortage where ago 16
Walmart customers
well I mean first of all I'd say you
know we're actually incredibly fortunate
to be in a business that's doing well
during these times when you look at from
other industries that have just gotten
decimated and and we've had a long
history of doing well during periods of
crisis so it's sort of part of our
culture and DNA and proud of how we've
executed through this that being said
it's it's hard and we're in really
difficult period
you mentioned the supply chain I mean
just to give you some sense of what
we've been dealing with you know when
when consumers first started hoarding
middle of March products we sold in in
ten days we basically sold our entire
year supply of water bottles that we had
expected his sell we've sold over a
hundred million extra eggs in the five
day period we sold enough toilet paper
rolls for everybody to have their own
roll around the world the statistics are
pretty astounding so you know in terms
of the challenges obviously keeping the
supply chain running as a challenge
we're learning to work in a different
way like you know just like the zoom
call so our our executives are all
working from home which is which is
different we operate in 27 countries and
we're finding there are obviously some
similarities across markets but also
some some differences with how every
country is dealing with this we've been
working closely with with the White
House and the administration as well as
it at state level on on how to help
testing and other things but
specifically your your first question
was on our associates and that's what we
call we don't actually call our
employees employees we call them
associates it goes back to when Sam
founded the company I mean we look at
all of the people that work in our
businesses as partners so with our
associates that's actually our first
priority is how do we keep we have two
and a half million people that that work
for us around the world and and how do
we keep them safe and so
you know we were one of the first
companies to implement new PTO policies
so we pay up we've actually have three
tiers of paid time off policy one is
just for people who don't feel
comfortable working in this environment
we have a set of ways to handle that
we've got a second level which are
people who have been exposed or worried
about you know the need to be
quarantined and then we have a third
level which are actually associates who
have tested positive for the virus and
in each level we've we've got policies
to address that so that we can keep our
workforce going and keep the stores open
but make sure that that folks feel safe
and that's that's been our top priority
thanks Greg yeah I delighted to hear
that and we count on you Walmart very
great shopping environment to support us
now you talk about the water being sold
when you supply ten days hopefully a
transitional you are able to catch up
with the production touch up with the
supply so that you don't have 16 we have
a 16 each of these materials we hope
that educates that seems more and more
normal supply back swimming more of the
standard situation yeah it's actually
it's interesting yes and no so yes the
items that consumers were initially
hoarding are now the supply chain is
catching up with that so that's you know
hand sanitizers are coming back toilet
paper
water all those things people could only
buy so much and use so much so those
items the supply chain is is catching up
there's a second level which are items
that with Chinese manufacturing being
down for a period of time there's
certain categories
but you know patio furniture and some
other things that just weren't
manufactured better more seasonal and
and but you know for a lot of those
categories demand is is down and then
there's a third category which is the
one that that were more focused on right
now and concerned about which is fresh
meat and you know the sympathy issues
which I'm sure you all have read about
in the press because those those fresh
processing plants are having issues this
isn't just you know this isn't us
specifically this is Tyson and
Smithfield and others that are having a
real challenge with their meat
processing plants and you know it's safe
environments and controlling the virus
so that that's really the area that
we're probably most concerned about at
this point
thank you talk about making sure the
supply line is also continuously flowing
these days public press companies
conservation of cash so that they are
payment suppliers don't pay them and so
on which the long term you can just yeah
I'll comment on one specific thing and
then talk more generally I know there
was an article in The Financial Times
maybe a week ago or two weeks ago which
was really an earnest report that you
know we were doing some things that were
affecting our suppliers in Bangladesh
that didn't seem fair and that's just
not it's just not an accurate article I
mean we if something if we have any with
any of our any of our supply chain are
both private label as well as CPG
companies that we work with you know if
we've got something that's in production
in process those aren't we you know we
don't cancel those words unless there's
some
you know there will be down the supply
chain there will I mean there are
certain categories where demand is going
down and that will impact manufacturers
across the globe which you know we're
gonna see everywhere but but we wouldn't
be we wouldn't be backing out of
contracts that we had signed at a
general level it's it's a good question
which is you know do you focus on during
these times you focus on cash you focus
on broader stakeholder values again I
think it I think it really depends on
the industry you're in I mean if you're
in if you're running a hotel lodging
business right now or an airline I mean
you're you're focused on trying not to
go into bankruptcy again we're a bit
more fortunate in that our our business
is pretty strong although it's different
by you know different by category but we
also as I mentioned at the start we've
got a long history and culture of when
things get difficult we say what's
what's the right thing to do we did it
during Hurricane Katrina and we've done
it with Houston flooding and all of that
and so all of our board conversations
have been around let's let's make sure
we do the right thing right now and and
that's taking care of our associates and
our customers and if there's some hipped
cash flow will we you know we can
withstand that a good example is we we
came out and we paid special bonuses to
all of our associates in the US which
averaged $300 an associate right away
when the when the crisis hit and then we
accelerated bonuses as well from that
was supposed to be paid and actually
early May we accelerated those two end
of March and we didn't we didn't need to
do either of those things but our view
was you know our associates we're gonna
be hit pretty hard and we wanted them to
you know we wanted to try and blunt some
of that impact if we could thank you for
sitting because that's a good example of
being a company that commits dedicated
associate stakeholders the supply chains
let's turn around
going forward I think some countries are
perhaps planning to get out of the cove
it might eat the worst situation we hope
that the rest of the country may also
start talk about recovery it fades many
people says that the retailing would
never be the same given that we have
experienced covetous owed what look at
the future of well but actually before
we get to that I think you know when you
and I talked before this class I think
there's a middle step right which is you
know before we get to talking about the
future I think the question is how do we
come out of where we are and part of
part of you know as you'd expect in my
role I talk to a lot of political
leaders business leaders academic
leaders and I I think part of the
challenge our country is is in right now
and other countries are in as is this
has become somewhat a binary question of
do we stay shelter in place or do we
reopen and our view that Walmart is that
we need to this conversation should be
more nuanced there's not one right
answer it you know I think it's gonna be
dependent on geography you're in when
what demographic you're in are you an
at-risk group we obviously need testing
that's the most critical thing and
that's that we believe that's that's
coming but we think we as a company can
help lead and this is one of things
we've been working with the White House
on and our CEO actually chairs the
Business Roundtable and and we're
working on what's the right plan to
emerge from this in the in the right way
and that can be again some of the PTO
policies providing the right PPE so that
people feel comfortable in the workforce
having special hours when you know
seniors might be able to shop but don't
feel comfortable normally going into the
store so anyway that's but put that
aside I'll go back to your the question
that you asked which is so
yes I think there will be some some more
permanent changes that come out of this
but but I think it's more I think there
were changes that were already coming
and this is accelerated that so we we've
our our business has been you know for
the last decade has gone through
dramatic changes and the whole digital
transformation is is significant and has
impacted all retailers what's happened
is since the virus a lot of those trends
have accelerated dramatically so you
know and we saw it first with we've
actually got a large business in China
with almost 500 stores and so we we saw
with our stores there which was we've
got a large part where our business is
actually grocery pick up where you can
place an order on an app on a website on
our website and pick it up and in
certain cases have it delivered and
those types of ordering spiked
dramatically first in China and then
we're seeing that in other parts of the
world and and that we think you know
that transformation was going to happen
it's just happening you know basically
what happened in a month was what people
were expecting to happen over the next
three or four years and a lot of that I
you know some of that will ease off
obviously once the some of the concerns
around the virus lesson but but the
transformation itself has is it's gonna
be a permanent one well thank you brett
so it's important for us to know that
Walmart is leveraging or perhaps
convening power to work with other other
groups to help us get out of this first
situation right so and then after that
going forward of format yes
but Walmart is already doing that Lord
with all my calm and so you see that as
maybe
an expanded version of my comm then what
would happen
Bridget mortar stores forward-looking
yeah we think we think there's always
going to be a place for physical stores
there's there's a community aspect to it
there's a lot of people who like you
know they'd love to go to our stores
it's it's there is you know personal
physical touch points which seem strange
right now but but in normal times for a
lot of people that that's something they
they really enjoy a lot of people like
picking out their own produce and fresh
foods and those types of things
but our you know our focus has been well
we've got a pure e-commerce business our
long-term focus has been on how do we
leverage our weapon thousand stores
around the world to provide added added
touch points and experiences for our
consumers yeah we think these worlds are
going to blend and you know with with
Whole Foods on the phone last week you
know that's that's Amazon now and Amazon
we're sort of approaching Amazon's world
from our physical stores perspective and
Amazon is coming from the digital side
and physical stores and and we believe
long-term of customers not gonna want to
have to choose exactly how they want to
shop they're gonna shop multiple ways
and that can be ordering in a store and
having a delivery to home if it's out of
stock it could be on an app but having
it you know driving by their store and
picking it up so so we think there's
always going to be a role for physical
stores to play and part of that might be
that they become almost more like part
of the supply chain as many depots where
they're they're almost like a
fulfillment know that's part of the
broader supply chain network but and
then we think stores will become you
know they'll likely become smaller over
time
and the even though we're we're not
building many big super centers anymore
we're relocating some but not many new
ones but the footprint that when we are
doing them now the footprint is smaller
than it was when we were building
centers you know 15 20 years ago thanks
Rick I know that Walmart has always
emphasized ensuring that as a hygiene is
sustainable whether its environmental
responsibility or social labor
compliance so Walmart has always been a
champion would covet 19 currently and
the very stressful time that you may say
well cannot push this as hard as we used
or this is a chance for say hey you're
not on board you won't be a continued so
how is this something so much you have
so many fires it so many things that you
have to take care of yeah it's
interesting I I am I think it's for us
it's really no change I mean I think if
we had sustainability efforts that were
that we were doing to enhance the
reputation of the company then I think
during this time we would back off on
those but everything we're doing around
supply chain we think makes us a better
company or around sustainability our
supply chain specifically we think makes
us a better company and more efficient
over time so you know we've got really
broad goals around emissions reductions
becoming a zero waste company improving
labor standards and none of those things
are are changing and I don't see us
taking a step back at all during during
this time period you know there might be
some minor things there are some
municipalities and places where you know
they're not allowing people to bring for
example their own shopping bags into the
stores and and you know we've been
trying to eliminate plastic shopping
bags over time that are a huge amount of
waste and there might be some things
like that that are temporary setbacks
but there's nothing within our broad
goals that we're changing or
reducing it at this point week so at a
high level which is something that you
would never compromise I think my team
is going to be continuing to but yet
there were a lot of calls within even
our politicians that says that we should
bring more jobs back to me where's look
what happened with our masks mostly
produce in China and we don't have
enough masks we don't have enough
protective gears bring more back and
this could be a terrorist thing it could
also be a sentiment of security it's
warm are we thinking about your global
sourcing strategy at this well first of
all on the tariff question
I mean we're big believers in we're
against tariffs we think protectionist
measures end up hurting customers I
think you know facing a global a
significant global recession like we are
right now would be the worst time to put
in place higher levels of tariffs and
any protectionist measures so because
it's gonna end up hurting hurting the
customer so we would be against that
we'd be vocal about that in terms of our
supply chain you know we're always
reassessing where we're buying goods
from and it's constantly shifting we
don't do it at a macro level so we don't
sit around a few of us in the conference
room and say we want X percent to come
from China and this percent to come from
Mexico and this percent to come from the
US that's that's really not how we make
sourcing decisions it's at a buyer an
item level where they're they're trying
to figure out what's what's how can we
offer the best value to our our
customers and and so because because the
decisions are made at that level it's
constantly shifting and you know there's
certain products like consumer
electronics that are almost exclusively
manufactured in China at this point and
and that's the best
ways to source them from so anyway we're
constantly surveying the world looking
for the best place to buy things we
still source around two-thirds of our
goods in the US so that's still the you
know the predominant share of our
sourcing but but we wouldn't we're not
making any decisions at a high level to
say if you know it should be more from
this country or less from this country
at this point I wanted to raise a
question I just mentioned saying that
M&A is perhaps a lot of retailers are
very tough positions
given that the as well-endowed compared
to Walmart or maybe their business model
is such that they cannot open during
this time two passes because you think
different I think the answer is maybe
you know in the u.s. we it'd be really
difficult for us to do a large you know
any kind of large acquisition of
physical stores just because of
antitrust and competition and all that
but but we're always evaluating the
landscape we tend to prefer or you know
sort of components of our business model
or strategy that we're missing and we if
we go find a great team with great
product or technology we tend to prefer
those types of acquisitions but if we're
involved if we're behind in certain
areas we're open to making acquisitions
that's what led to the jet acquisition a
few years ago which really accelerated
our e-commerce business we didn't have a
meaningful presence in India and we made
the Flipkart acquisition to really spur
our efforts there so well
always we're always you know surveying
the landscape and and but I'm not sure
you know some if there's a physical
retailer that's going out of business
I'm not sure that's something that
that's gonna be appealing to us thank
you
I have a personal question to you
personally as a chairman of how much to
worry about execution mostly focusing
your time as a chairman
I sometimes get the draft into issues
like yeah you know it's a good question
and you know the chairman role at
companies differs pretty dramatically
depending on the company and the
individuals involved for us at Walmart
we've had a history of we've always had
a Walton family member chair so I'm
married to Sam Wong's granddaughter and
I'm the third chairman in our history
and we've we've always had a
professional CEO that's outside the
family since Sam so run our fifth CEO
now in Doug McMillon and then we've had
a great tradition of our Chairman
working closely with the CEO so my
office in Arkansas is right next to his
and he and I talked every day I tend to
play a more active role probably the
most chairmen but but that part that's
the history of how we've operated and I
like to stay focused on the on the big
picture strategy M&A capital structure
significant executive hires those types
of things that's right me I can add the
most value but because of how our
company operates which you mentioned if
you don't understand the detail of how
we're working it's actually hard to add
value on the bigger picture questions so
I usually spend we've got something we
call meeting week once a month where we
bring all of our senior executives from
around the world make sure everybody's
in Arkansas for that week at our
headquarters and that's when we have our
finance meeting or M&A meeting or
officers meeting real estate meetings
and so we have a series of meetings
during that whole week that I you know I
attend as well and that's where I make
sure I really keep my pulse on on what's
happening in a more detailed level that
then enables me to add value on the on
the bigger picture questions oh that's
great I think I want to use the
remaining time to have students ask new
questions directly Jenna generous spirit
so Jenna can you start hi yes okay
wonderful
thank you so much for being here Greg um
you'd mentioned already the stakeholder
view and the Business Roundtable has
pledged that Walmart has been a
signatory as I was curious for a little
bit more insight into how that pledge
affects conversations at the board level
and with shareholders during this time
mm-hmm
you know it's interesting the companies
probably view that pledge in different
ways for us that pledge because that's
how we've always operated the pledge
didn't actually for us it didn't make a
significant difference in terms of how
we act so when we're having board
conversations or I'm talking Doug and I
are making decisions we don't I don't
ever we don't ever really think about
the pledge specifically because it's so
ingrained and in our culture and how we
we operate so we we tend I'm just
thinking about recent Congress
you know when we've had to make
trade-off decisions let's just say it's
a cache decision vs. reputation or
treating our associates right I mean we
tend to and our board is in alignment
with us on this you know we always come
back to question more around what's
right to the long term so if something
is the right decision for the next six
weeks or eight weeks or ten weeks but
it's not going to be good a year from
now we never make that decision and it's
it gets to another topic which is is it
good to have a shareholder like our
family that owns 50% of the business and
and I'm a strong proponent I think it is
because it allows the management team
and the board to have the confidence to
make decisions that are might not be
right for a quarter but are right for
the long term and a lot of companies
talk about that but when you get down to
it and how decisions are actually made a
lot of times you know the incentives get
skewed a bit and we're fortunate to be
in a position where we don't we don't
have to make that trade-off of
sacrificing the long term for short-term
gain good thanks Jenna and thanks Craig
for answering Jana's question I see
Laurence next yes thank you very much
great call so from my side and my
question was around purchasing patterns
and how you think they might change for
the average American consumer as a
result of this not necessarily in the
short term so while Cova is happening
but what might this do to what people
buy how much they spend how much they'll
be saving and I'd love to also
understand how you as a business and as
a strategy team think through a question
like that what sort of data do you use
how do you who do you engage to have to
come to a conclusion on this so on the
latter question we I mean we we've
always had incredible data around
purchase behavior we've tended to have
less customer data which may sound like
kind of an obvious thing but you know a
lot of companies have really good
customer day
we've always had really good purchase
data just based on how our our systems
work and transactions and but anyway so
we would look to that data and then it's
really close partnerships with our our
suppliers is how decisions are made
around categories shifting um you know
it's interesting I don't know at this
point I don't know that there will be
any dramatic shifts in categories based
on this I mean there will be some as we
talked about earlier I think there will
be behavioral shift in terms of how
people purchase but I'm not sure there
will be significant category shifts
based on this at least not not ones that
we're seeing yet but yeah that could
change I mean we're obviously we're
going to have a period of much lower
demand just because of the unemployment
levels and so eul's you'll see the
impact of that with discretionary items
but that'll be a short to medium term
phenomenon Lobby on the subject of
patching or purchasing I think that the
question that was always related to
particular food yeah yes actually I have
two questions one of them is bearing in
mind the fact that the the hospitality
and the restaurants are closed right now
so the portion of the food industry that
was catering to them so a certain extent
is not accessed how long do you think
for food wheat retailers or bigger
retailers such as yourself for them to
be able to keep to capture that that
market are you expecting inflationary
moments in the food sector overall and
my third question is because of this
coverage crisis do you expect a move to
do you expect the change in formats
meaning they expect more people will be
going to you know format such as Aldi
will you be considering shifting your
size
how are you going to be is do you think
this is going to be part of your
strategy or decision-making post co-ed
yeah let me address them in reverse
order so on the on the format question I
don't think it's gonna lead to new
formats but I but as as we talked about
I think it will accelerate certain
trends so another trend which I didn't
mention earlier is you know department
stores have been struggling and you know
this this is going to be really
difficult for for those types of
retailers to survive what's happening
right now and because we're going into a
recession the low cut you know the
discount low-cost retailers like an Aldi
Lidl ourselves Dollar General they they
will naturally do better during during
this time period in terms of inflation
you know we're not seeing it yet but
this is such a crazy time and and things
are moving so fast and I mean you saw
what happened with oil this week I mean
who knows what's gonna happen next week
and where the shortages might have if
you know if all of a sudden all the meat
process you know meat plants are down
you might see some spikes there but but
we're not we're not seeing anything
anything dramatic at this point and then
you know for restaurants and you know
there had been a shift to more
ready-made meals that had you know
another long term trend that had been
been happening it's interesting because
part of this accelerates that which is
eating at home but part of it is
actually a negative because now people
like if you go to a grocery store there
are no ready-made people aren't doing
those types of things where you pick up
prepared food anymore from grocery
stores because those parts the stores
are all all bare and shut down so I
don't I don't know how that I don't know
whether this accelerates or decelerates
that that trend over time thanks Jim
maybe we'll take the last question is
that
yes thank you so much for for taking the
time quick
I was wondering at you you talked about
that Mitte step that used to happen
before we reopen the economy properly
and and given that there seems to be a
somewhat disjointed approach on this and
some states are opening up right now
some are not how is a company like woman
navigating this and what sources of
information do you rely on and Trust in
terms of formulating your policies about
this so the answer yes we've had to
essentially formulate our own policies
and and then a lot of the retail
industry has has followed that so our
policy around leaves are we were the
first ones to provide PPE you know the
protective equipment for folks in the
stores that then the CDC mandated that
we started the social distancing and
marketing the stores now other retailers
are doing that so you know everybody is
learning at the same time and we're you
know we're reading as much as we can
we're talking to as many people as we
can we're talking to our suppliers we're
out in the stores you know visit you
know I go visit stores all of our
executives are visiting stores talking
to customers talking to our associates
and it's it's again how how we learn and
then we have we have weekly meetings
where right now they're virtual but you
know typically we come together every
Friday in an auditorium and we talk
about what we're seeing and hearing in
them and then we make decisions from
there and and so our processes right now
are just iterative based on that but we
don't have one so frankly but there just
is not nobody knows exactly what's
happening so if you read anybody who
says I know the answer they don't know
what they don't know the answer because
nobody knows exactly how this is gonna
roll out nobody has perfect data you've
seen all models all the predictive
models out there but their predictions
based on very limited testing and and I
think we're gonna see you know we've got
case studies of how different countries
are approaching this different states
will approach
in varying ways and we're just gonna
continue to learn and adapt as quickly
as we can but we don't have a we don't
have a blueprint yet for exactly how
that's gonna how that's gonna work so I
hope you all join me in thanking Greg
for spending time with us so we really
will really appreciate really appreciate
it
[Music]